good morning good morning day happy
Monday
hey Rob hi Eric are you doing great what
kind of a butt stuff are we gonna get
into today dude
an endless amount of butt stuff - your
butt's content you're gonna get a lot of
butt stuff in this game a lot of farts
and it'll get me it'll I'm one to laugh
at a fart joke Eric I can it'll happen
and I think you all will too all right I
hope so I hope you're right here we go
we're doing South Park fractured but
whole butt home and yeah if you guys are
tuning in on twitch YouTube GameSpot
thank you guys for all tuning in
some people are white guys slowly
trickle in but thank you guys for tuning
in that you know with me and Rob start a
new game for you guys just so you can
check out the character creator Eric I
know it starts off good tips on the
loading screen so read loading screen
tips if you want to know more Dead game
yeah okay got it
okay I love you pretty hard when I saw
that so this we're starting a new game
Eric I have played about 10 hours okay
sweet how long has the game roughly I
think it's I heard Miguel of the guy who
reviewed it here said he it took him
about 15 hours I think that's
understandable
yeah so maybe a little bit more not sure
that was the last time I asked him it
was like the rough can you give me a
rough amount of time yeah so yeah the
review is up our Miguel concepción
reviewed it it got an 8 which I believe
I'm gonna say on our scale is great is
that what it is
let me see yeah it's great actual like
great weight is great know where you're
not playing on a pro I always probably
listen to this
greatness what has become of this city
there used to be laws justice not
anymore
cran is out of control cats are missing
and townspeople are being victimized Oh
who pooped on my porch we were supposed
to protect those who couldn't protect
themselves girl for core you will Parker
now superheroes are torn apart by
political differences we are two sides
at war
[Music]
but lore isn't going to save our city
time travel is my only hope now myths
tell of ancient times when a new king
United a kingdom torn apart by a
powerful stick
I
there's no time to waste I have to go
back change the present if I can find
this cat and in doing so perhaps I can
change what has happened
[Music]
[Music]
pretty good all right here we go
character creator all right uh I mean
once it looks pretty extensive yeah any
good and the more you play the more
hairstyles we unlock and yeah clothing
options that is a consistent thing this
is like how Kyle's hair here is brown
well
mohawk Mohawk so let's make a character
here what do you guys think yeah yeah
you do tell me when we have a early
version a review version review copy but
we are allowed to stream it so that is
how we're playing so yeah what are you
gonna make a monster or a pretty normal
person can you even make a look at what
hairstyle that is that totally the
hairstyle of your character is a Titan
from the first game shut up
let's tell you yeah it is let's do a
Mark Hamill alright Mark Hamill Luke
Skywalker alright young Luke not old
blue that's right
that old man Luke alright the game
doesn't come out until tomorrow or
probably like early today depend on how
you look at it I'm not do you know if
it's a 9 p.m. here kind of thing like
12:00 a.m. Eastern would be 9 p.m. here
I should look that's just best probably
right did Mark didn't have glasses no go
bald why do we wanna go bald
now you're going Mark Hamill you're
committed right yeah honestly you want
to get past this stuff as soon as
possible oh really
I well I just think a lot of this game
so I again I played a while a lot of it
and I said this is the difficulty joke
but this is a joke right because it's
you guys had played it tried it it
doesn't actually change the the actual
difficulty it's a joke as new in Ryan
but there are some people saying that
like references are different like
slightly different when you enter a room
rest earlier was saying yeah I haven't
really noticed myself well are you
playing a No so that's probably it but
you know it's I wouldn't be able to like
differentiate I guess
all right the Great War right after the
first game whoops
guys if it kicks off with a nice fart
minigame not bad so like some of those
prompts are kind of hard to understand
what's a deuce masta seems you got a
good handle on Dusen your friends are
downstairs kiddo get out there I didn't
even read the item you picked up it was
an anal itch away on the right yeah
what's he doing you pick up so many
different scrap you do nothing that big
a deal
that's Dubrow mr. browning
yeah get that rowdy but it all starts
somewhere ech addictions gateway the
gateway drug it was tough
so you're going around like to play a
game no I can't play a game there that's
that's I always gonna say the meta the
game within the game mm-hmm so what I
would say though is that you know you
you're doing scavenging cuz you do bunch
of crafting later look at all that deco
playing or cloth are like the main
component for making new costumes and
stuff yeah has your opinion change the
can start now I know like last week you
weren't that big on it you're like kind
of like you know it's it's just kind of
slow burn like for me I'm here just for
southpark so I feel like they're like
they were really slowly kind of rolling
out abilities and in kind of even
characters in general
I know it I have us in the top right I
hope that's a good spot I mean even yeah
it looks like it doesn't subscribe well
I'm kind of getting at is that uh
can i watch this kind of introduction
and she's teaching you how to do all the
fighting yeah in case you didn't play
the first one yeah because this is part
of the game for sure
ooh fisticuffs you're badass yeah Mark
Hamill don't miss Mark Hamill so you're
also doing a I didn't show it there so I
guess what I'm really trying to say is
it takes a while to like get to the
actual nudity of the game we're like I'm
enjoying myself
because they roll out all these
different functions with your phone you
have a phone right there it has your GPS
your crafting skills like the other
things that like they roll out fast
travel really late so I'm going down the
same paths over and over again guys like
first I want to see four hours that was
just kind of like frustrating where I
was getting like I wanted to laugh like
the first game baby died laughing I felt
like that happened pretty quickly but
the more I've been playing again I'm
about halfway through I think it's been
like totally picking up and I've been
enjoying it so play it's a slow burn you
wanna get it totally gets there yeah
like really late last night so this is
super basic like your powers and like
different all the kids in the have in
town like there's a handful of ones that
are alike and play with and you pick
your team your and their abilities and
they're very class based so you have
like kind of like your vampire health
stealer one or like Kyle is a his name
is the human kite yeah well you use from
like twelve classes right ultimately
that you can play as so then those are
your own classes I'm talking about like
just your team
yeah and anyway yeah yeah exactly you
roll out like three different subclasses
as the game goes on
so in terms of difficulty - I heard you
speaking this morning that you had like
accidentally played on the hardest
difficulty and even then it wasn't like
that hard it was more just like it took
longer it was harder yeah I just it just
took long it took more visits turn-based
right and you're not moving your whole
team at once you're playing back and
forth or however the game wants to do it
[Music]
so for those just tuning in we're
planning south part the fractures butt
hole and this is the beginning of the
game but we're gonna probably in like
20-30 minutes we'll probably kind of
skip ahead to one of Rob's more in the
middle save and check that out so yeah
it looks like just to get you guys a
feel for how this how this starts off
though I may even skip around like not
to where I am but like at some point in
between I didn't move so this is another
game where it's like there's someone's
going to throw something in to turn so
move your team out or else they're gonna
take damage a lot of damage so sometimes
get the past your turn because some of
your abilities yeah your reach or like
they're only diagonal or only in front
of you or to the right they'll do other
similarities they're like jokes yeah
they will look damn kids
I guess I'm trying to finish up my
thought earlier is that again it just it
just takes a while to even get
comfortable with like the controls and
like because you want to go through
fighting smoothly opposed to like
spending so much time with like
I guess what I'm saying is it like once
you get all your team under you you can
start liking you can start seeing like
stuff like teams and like where you fit
in do I want to play as a healer well
make sure someone else is or my team is
more like you know damage dealers that
just takes like I want to say five six
hours so I guess you kind of answer that
but I'll just ask a question just in
case because it's from mario cat 500 in
youtube how are you liking this so far
compared to single truth i didn't last
time dude the timing of it wow you died
from that yeah let's watch this when i
write do the next in south
Oh whatever ewout normally it always
goes you're dead I know that's why I
turned it up into the ocean lies you
shall feel the wrath of a Moorish unhand
him you heathens tomorrow you'll have
the King to do it the king they say he
can play a dragon with one blow that's
right and if you don't wait wait I
thought he was with you guys now we got
a distress they know to come help him
gear wizard in town
my name is the kid I'm from the future
good we said we're not playing got any
more yeah we're all split up what's the
point this is the point in Matt time
there is a massive crime wave and
missing cats
I knew my only hope was to assemble the
team hey you picked which games like
this where's the stick of truth shut up
Kevin isn't about some dumb stick
there's a cat in trouble and it's the
key to finding the crime syndicate new
to our town in the future I've said
again that
that sounds too heavy for Gounod man
well what do you want Clyde you're the
[ __ ] freedom pals to find the missing
cat getting $100 reward
I make their superhero franchise more
popular the freedom pound dude
that's right go get your stuff and
report back to the cool air sorry guys
you can't play with us we're playing
superheroes now and you guys are dorks
oh you need to see a doctor for that now
play in the street protip good street
they'll play in the streets so yeah this
is all like kind of setup to like you
switching now to you know the different
franchise back there I guess yeah
because now it's gonna be more of the
superheroes transitioning off of the
first game right this second game it's
too so this was like yeah roughly 50 to
20 hours Jacob not sure I'm sure that
time varies depending on how much stuff
you want to do how much exploring you
want to do Denver Nuggets
oh yeah what is that will speed through
this wow what is that Wow mr. carp
yeah he's got beef he's got beef but no
it's not hot but my son told me I will
burn to death by trying
oh yes he did tell me that if I step on
a crack break my mother's back there's
no anything that's not enough mosquito
we have to act fast before the freedom
pals can a hundred dollar reward do you
know what that could mean to our
superhero franchise that cat looks
pretty old maybe just died in the gutter
somewhere
human kite do I have to remind you that
as of right now freedom pals have a
hundred followers on Instagram we have
six the five of us and Billy Turner
who's a ginger this is the key to
finally beating those [ __ ] but where
do we start looking that cat could be
anyway we need to split up
mosquito take to the air and check out
all the city parks you got it mosquito
away so that's Clyde you know sometimes
you just can't tell right where [ __ ]
you can count on to get dip
[Laughter]
hola
sarcasm wants to know how much of the
gear is cosmetic it's all the pic top
left okay we can do that told you you
can't say you aren't a superhero you
don't have a costume you're are these
superpowers yeah alright look you can
watch us play superheroes as long as you
don't get in the way make yourself
useful go grab me this the furnace ii
device it's over there
ya rabb be useful so again the games is
slowly rolls out all the system systems
in play so i think we should skip ahead
all right then go full camera here okay
cool
sweet who would the burrito whisper
whisper sweet oh so we're definitely not
doing the strip club yeah because that
is yeah graphic
yeah real graphic the burrito whisper
our paper route to block it
oh you'd have a long I got it guys like
it would be a difficult time to do that
so I wonder how anyone gets away with
that part of it during a stream though I
don't I don't know how cuz its graphic
and it's kinda spoiled leave I can't
know how much order Lauren Gerrie though
yeah but like the boss battle for that
one is look at you it's different yeah
sorry this is my fit so I can really
show everyone what you're looking at
like this is probably yes
refer to you can make it however you
want it so I can like yeah we huh yes
I'm yaoi
normal
Rob I don't know just because wait what
yeah we do you know what that means
oh no oh okay so you're collect these
are collectibles that you're looking for
boy love it's a guy looks like they're
so yearly and sort of like Sasuke
there's a guy in town who's collecting
these yeah it's tweek and Craig if you
know South Park they they're in love and
here's your crafting section um so you
get recipes for different types of gear
but they don't do anything else no no
not really
but you get a crafter rank so you want
to keep making stuff in order to make
the higher-end clothes does that change
as you get make like a higher crafter
right yeah if you like see it on the top
right so yeah certain items are like no
univie craft ranked 10 in order to craft
it so you like we're constantly trying
to like fine recipes and we're done if
you want wear something cool you kind of
gotta do that and then artifacts are
like kind of like just perks right so
the more you play that you get more as
you go along and they're all they're
kind of generic like you just want to
have a high might score so it's kind of
its kind of like destiny in that
respects like you're just right I might
score and then you're and then you're
selling these back to like other
merchants that's it for and then later
on you get different types of slots that
won't really talk about and then what
else we got here to show off this is
just like challenges to focus on if
there's a lot of stuff so that's what if
someone is comparing the last games if
there's a lot more but systems
yeah so I went to Tom's rhinoplasty and
I was able to get a butt chin because I
thought that was cool with him and then
you get I'll get into these summons
later so there's four sick the pretty
funny picture so in battle I get like
only one opportunity in a given battle
to he comes in and just like beefs up
health and shield to all my weak dudes
and then artifacts I've enjoying and
then you get the foods to graham so
really early on you are meeting people
this is kind of like how the a lot of
the
sub quests kind of come into play where
it's like the priests won't
I need selfies in order to get more
followers which is another factor is
like get ready now so yeah any more than
we started with a paranoid I think I got
like like 10,000 now just again earlier
safe but again this is kind of how sub
quests work where he's like I won't take
a selfie with you until you bring me
back wha sorry you had 474 followers
you're falling do you so Google has
question how do you unlock all the
classes is that something that just it's
a part of the story
whoa the double ok the doobly the dupa
dupa side right the double double just
do cuz the best part about this game is
like the main story right like where
you're it's where you're hearing Trey
Parker that's all I want to hear is like
Trey Parker and Matt Stone let's do it
cuz these characters don't like a lot of
the NPC's that are random aren't are not
like don't sound like Matt chose oh but
let's take a look at requests I have
here go to France tacos alright tacos
welcome to Freeman's tacos if there's
anything I can interest them in well you
just let me know
I love this place because you can crap
whatever food items you want
so most places also say here's another
lose collectible
all right and then most places have of
course this minigame so I'm not gonna
lie they're not there all right I
there's something about over that I kind
of enjoy there's a bad bad gas it up so
yeah it just kind of tricky okay you
know it's like the pair of these like
you know brush your teeth while brushing
your hair type stuff like your mind kind
of a saliva way person smooth yeah so
our class is locked my story or can you
finish the game is to start over with
one of the unlocks I will ask you that
again menu woo the skin got gas it up
trying every time you need time okay we
are Africa it's left right okay
and I'll buy even my poo does not look
like that like a blue drip of food oh he
did wipers but okay but no toll bigger
okay so wait let me that's like good
question all right our class is like my
story can you finish the game to start
over with one of the Ahmadis yeah I
don't know about that but I doubt it I
think you would start to start a whole
new one
chin sac baby that's right Jacob maybe
when you're better at crafting I'll take
a selfie see I tried to take a selfie
with him he said no so now I Freeman's
tacos is completely craft your own you
know what crafting is don't you just
open up that crafting menu what's up
Carlos beef from Brownsville Texas how
are you doing you can combine food items
into whatever you like let's start with
a staple the burrito warm tortilla
wrapped around well any old something
here I'll give you what you need to get
started this year now it's just now that
you have your first taste of crafting
let's dig in
you can combine food items into whatever
you like and go ahead see what happens
if you combine a burrito and an
enchilada congratulations new kid with
an enchilada and a burrito you've
crafted an injury - it's the first time
anyone's ever done have a few more
recipes they might just save your stupid
ass
alright okay I didn't do that last time
the curly Sanchez so you you know as you
go along the game you get different kind
of abilities in the open world to let
interact with stuff so a lot of it a lot
of the game is gated as far as like more
thing chess they say that some parts are
so powerful they can actually bend the
fabric of time you be careful out there
man that's the body has played or
watched some teams use a head of the
line there but wow that aura so for
instance later on and I can look at a
chest yeah so I can't get up here but
later on you get the ability of a kid to
come and hide them there okay so that's
a lot of the gating is you want to play
more more of the story in order to get
it that's fine so what do I do now no
you gotta talk to the kun kun so
obviously la ville up there I can't yet
stop these cats I can't really interact
with yet I gotta find the one thing I
will say that's frustrating is like fast
travel can be rough until you actually
cuz you said you didn't get it till
later or is there right there
the one near now yeah but I have to be
at that fast travel so actually there's
one over here I go to sweet is that lava
on the ground yeah so I can't go this
way yet yeah the customer clapping was
pretty funny ooh
good job you can fight those guys thank
you so I can do this so this is
interesting too is I can like fart fart
on them so then when I start this fight
they'll have they'll be grossed out and
we'll be taking kind of poison damage
but here's one of these
hey it's faster so you want to go out of
your way to get these fast rebels early
on so you don't have to like do so much
walking because I feel like or again if
I could give a hot tip would be that
yeah yeah how fast he came pass turn on
subtitles thank you go boom
what's up Rio Shima saying good
afternoon epic gamers and South Park
lovers absolutely travel on three equal
ride along maybe Jacob didn't put those
two together actually here we go oh yeah
three oh seven or is it sometimes it
changes oh really
yeah still three or something or f you
want all right you guys see at the table
now mm-hmm okay I think you show some
potential and I'm gonna upgrade you to
somebody sidekick or something
congratulations okay good I just maybe
wanted to talk about your superhero
character a little bit um your character
sucks
to be honest and I think I'm gonna let
you do a class let's pick another
ability to add so what kind of skill set
are you looking to add to your
repertoire what wha so what I have you
start with three so I think this happens
three times breathing go back and
combine these and then swap out your
abilities yourself so like ones of these
different classes so right now I have
like a like a basically the flash I can
like zip around that like combat zone
pretty quickly and that supposed to be
the thing so weird ah cute right so this
is just your hard hitter and this is
ranged and there's Professor X on the
far right
yeah I picked him so his super does like
a heel for everyone on this sidebar
cyborg actually cyborg shut the female
version I have not seen this one yet
SiC but now we're gonna need to change
your backstory too so let's go back
again to that fateful night this happens
every time you did lay awake that night
but the reason you couldn't sleep was
because you wanted to make the world a
safer place you walk to the mirror yes
you have to walk in here you mess around
oh they'll be like oh you walked in a
mirror I did it the first time you
looked in the mirror and wondered if
anyone would ever love you so then you
heard a noise but but it was a baby
crying
out in the hallway you thought you guys
attacking a helpless baby on the floor
you've had to stop them from hurting
that baby didn't you you knew you had
the power to stop them and so you called
upon your newly discovered power power
surge do your cybernetic appendages as
you focused on your prime directive
protect the baby that for some reason
with loitering in your home hey what are
you doing here kid
but little did the intruders know that
you weren't just any kid you had been
cybernetically enhanced with a suite of
shocking abilities you demonstrated on
your victim you can't just knock him
back like that yeah what gives hey wait
up damaging all of them at once but you
still had many more cybernetic tricks up
your sleeve
[Music]
[Applause]
[Laughter]
Lyndsay on the intruder took a swing at
you put your block absorb the damage
this is a cool way of introducing yeah
yeah it's the kind of the same event but
different every time it's an ongoing
joke kind of it's great oh yeah this is
a good one they don't attract you oh hey
that's pretty cool that's good and then
I could use like mosquito as a character
I have that says like up Oh não não é
like poisoning yes right what you think
about your team who big gun alright so
here's what this super these are always
kind of funny they tried
[Music]
he's more machine than man you swept the
baby up in your arms to take him
somewhere safe and then that's when the
unthinkable happened
you saw your dad [ __ ] you from then on
you had to live with the fact because
you were busy helping the baby
that's heavy man I'm really sorry I know
you probably want to know why Wow your
dad [ __ ] your mom
those are answers you'll have to find
for yourself looks like you might be
meeting those new powers
dang oh yeah installed it was shared not
Celine Dion I'm an idiot of course sure
[Music]
powers that thank you for that sober
cross ACK
so cool so yeah once you get your second
subclass you can then swap out abilities
so I have one that can like you know I
can use two moves in one turn but then I
lose my chance as a I lose a turn so
it's it's like a nice finisher right I
know I can like end the match sooner
than later
yeah but let's swap out for like one of
these new cyborg ones so I love that
Celine Dion right sure you mean cher
cher Jesus and then I could be tough
party of none said that this [ __ ] just
isn't funny to me my 13 year old self
however would be dying right now I agree
to a to a degree I would say fits that
the thing I've been noticing is that
like I I first started playing the game
like exploring and I don't know maybe
doing a little too much of that up close
playing the main quests and the main
quest is like has been pretty worthwhile
for me that's where I've been actually
posted like all the fart jokes
everywhere it's it's non-stop fart I do
laugh sometimes though viewer discretion
it doesn't actually matter what race you
pick it's like a fake difficulty thing
it's like a joke even if we had picked
you know an african-american character
it's still the same I mean the only
difference is we've heard so far is that
like there might be different references
to you when you enter a room so like
Peter Brown our reviews like managing
manager of our reviews basically said
that like we heard some people call you
a thug or it's getting really urban in
here some
that's a dialogue because you're a
traitor to me and now you're with a
group of super traders this was started
by you by people who thought there
should be preferential treatment to
certain heroes we aren't the ones who
walked out of the [ __ ] franchise
mysterion all right
you must listen to me right now I was
speaking to you telepathically get out
of my head Timmy your franchise is going
nowhere
face the truth you guys are kind of
douchebags
he's just caught his douchebags in my
night he can't fight you son of a [ __ ]
back
[Music]
dr. Goodman Filipino
so there you'll really see the combat
coming to play when you're playing with
like all four yeah that's weird it
wasn't let me start like mosquito the
most and then I'll use that share where
I'm gonna screw that up all day now and
I'll throw this so the one thing is I do
have defensive prompts with there's mass
X kinda like it's kind of easy what's
not a timing thing
it is a timing thing yeah well it won't
like that's what's kind of testing is it
won't like give you consequences for
missing it so I used mash it but that's
affecting my super so if I'm missing
those prompts that I'm not getting my
supers are pretty cool right yeah
they're the funniest and motion
enjoyable all right now you're the human
kite so I'm more of a healer than
anything else so I'll probably
those are times those prompts when
you're when you're using your actual
character no I get I think freedom is my
son doesn't happen everything Craig's
pretty funny I just like it's funny cuz
he just gives little to no effort in his
character just I hate finger huh
[Music]
but my barrage
ah ketchup yes car watch out for the car
what are you gonna do now what do you
got what other sick moves you got the
magnet one that was pretty good so I
picked elementalist as my second
subclass and it came with a really cool
one where I'm very heal your human kite
I can't get too uh okay okay yeah so
he's more again just your healer yep if
you do oh no I don't have that angle
just anyone in that horizontal plane
nice but you can also aim well tip can
be horizontal well that's a cool one to
like bring guys back like Timmy is is
like kinda like the flash so he can like
or your oh it's ready oh okay cool ah
Craig's is pretty funny we could do
Craig's we'll get through a couple alone
yeah
you are drying way too hard this was
kind of weak I'm not sure this was sure
it's no more longer like the ones I said
earlier seeker rush
[Music]
cher oh there goes Kyle no I don't even
have my other ability so you get like
tons of more buildings like you're able
to like kind of like one time use type
stuff like as you talk to more different
characters like there's one it's like a
fart a fart
breaking time type thing where I get one
option to like rewind time and erase one
of their moves
so something like that was super
damaging right I lost my phone to my
guys granted I can get like revived
potions too
I don't have that I had revived which
you craft or buy yeah this was kind of
funny to see these are summons I get
also
but old debts be forgiven and all slaves
free
[Music]
crazy heel yeah I've only gotten one
other one which was Jimbo and I his slow
they saw places all right let's try this
one again
finish Tupperware this is Craig can be
tough right cuz he doesn't have anything
like on the other plane really he's just
always like more like straight yeah and
of course on a plane or everyone call it
you are - this guy
so what do you like what is your end
like in bold in this game I guess and go
or the story around it you're just
trying are you just trying to save the
cat right I guess like money so that you
become the best superhero franchise
instead of the mysterion's that the
friend the friendship pals or whatever
yeah they're like but there's a couple
of different ones right like there's
also fester chaos is another enemy who's
trying to like screw with me so that
there's kind of different plot lines I
guess you could say going around and as
well as all the sides stuff so like I
don't know Randy's pretty funny in this
Randy just keeps coming back I don't
really want to spoil it
he's always showing up this drug it's
pretty great he'll come up and just like
change up the play we fight for a little
bit but it's his mental powers are too
strong so we did all that for nothing
not quite I got Kenny cellphone you did
super
your presence is requested at City Hall
the mayor of South Park wishes to speak
with you don't make her wait so I'm
gonna keep doing they're doing mean
questioning stuff okay sounds good okay
why don't we do this cuz this was really
funny
alright let's do it we do have oh it's
gonna come naturally what am I saying
okay I'm trying to think of where my
save is okay this is great
so it works out oh yeah I'll set it up
cuz it was really funny to me so you
first off and you run you walk by Randy
and he is buffing out his car someone
had keyed his car like there's crazy
scratches on it so that's the only setup
I'll say okay is that you one of the
first sidequest you get right in the
beginning is it's like Oh help Randy
find out who's Kings car as well just
keep playing this and should happen
Jacob a whole singer saying Randy is one
of the best south bar characters oh for
sure you apparently I guess tweek is on
meth confirmed in cicatriz well his dad
keeps giving him coffee
maybe there's no Timmy's boat has a
bunch of notes in it something about a
girl who has information about all the
criminal activity of town what girl
it just says spied the girl with the
dick tattoo what girl in town has a dick
tattoo
I don't know this must be like dragon
pals must think she's the key to finding
the missing cat
if the freedom house find her before we
do they'll get the hundred dollar reward
we cannot let that happen we have to
stop the freedom pals from having a
sweet franchise at all costs then we
have to find the girl with that tattoos
tonight that passes right we all have to
sneak out of our houses tonight and
search the entire town you up for it
yeah let this guy join us anyway go easy
on him you guys he's had a tough life
when he was six years old his dad [ __ ]
his mouth
what I'm sorry friend but it's time they
learned you're a tragic backstory
butthole doesn't trust anyone because
his dad [ __ ] his mom Oh couldn't do
anything this time
that doesn't make any sense I know how
could the person you trust do that to
the only other person you love Carbon
everyone's dad [ __ ] everyone okay so
does that mean you're dead that's why
I'm here
don't steal his backstory dude that's
not this is not what's important right
now we need to find the lady with the
dick tattoo yeah let's get up so we can
prepare for evening missions
let's go [ __ ] friends friend you'll have
to deal with that kind of bigotry your
whole life by hope when people don't
understand that yeah it's in the family
coffee yeah that's right just straight
change into a random thing or you need
to change
oh you're going home so the other thing
too is um well like you know the
follower base meccanica out of the [ __ ]
and friends right like everyone the
town's start recognizing you when you're
in costume so forth like oh it's the
vigilante based on your reputation yeah
Jacob he has ketchup packets as ammo or
what's kind of neat our lease I'm happy
is that you can always change what you
look like
like you'll unlock like BAE BAE as a
character and the really popular girl
she starts giving you like hairstyles
and stuff or selling it to you again
like well it's pertaining to your
crafting skill or rank so he's got
double balls oh god do this
screw it white hair dang look to you
yeah look at me and I can always change
but that was pretty good right sure the
double chin strong chin anyways alright
let's go let's go
so you're still doing story stuff or the
thing there anything is where I'm doing
hard of it okay so I'm going back home
because I have to go to sleep and I have
to go to the strip club at night nice
the truth yes I said we were aware of
our child's gender issues you dumb [ __ ]
you'll ruin everything this from a stone
down pothead I need a drink sure drown
your problems in Chardonnay you stupid
skank
oh hey whippersnapper have a fun day out
playing well I'm exhausted
gotta get ready for bed dinner's on the
table if you wanted Punk but then
straight to bed okay pothead alcoholic
this the parent stuff is this is the
least interesting as far as this main
story goes it's like that that's the
same joke every time I don't know that's
the one thing I was just like yeah like
I want it's old it's old but it's like
these are fake characters from the
franchise right like they're made up for
you when all you really want to see is
like you know the Randy butters tally
tally I don't a lot of this I don't want
to spoil this is my bedroom where's mine
oh you can do this always oh yeah let's
just see them cry and his weed brownie
it's like every time there's a plot
development it's like I that's the same
thing with the parents so it's like I
don't know it's just kind of boring
minor but you I you always get you stuff
in here too you want to come back to
your room daga chipper Ito's yep chipper
eatos
sweetie I just want you to know that
whatever happens mommy always loved you
good night sweetheart
but that dialogue was based off of like
without an option you chose right you
that's when the creeps come out but
unfortunately for the creeps the other
thing that comes out at night
so some the chats are again there yeah
like just like earlier you saw who was
it who asked about me did we get to any
of those points you like people ask you
questions about your gender your race
and so your carrot as the game cuz you
do story beats you start filling out the
left side there God so I imagine some
point like the power source huh having
that was the first one oh you do ask
that - so kryptonite I don't know when
this has any play yet there's a list of
different things in the bottom left
there you again I haven't met any crab
people yet that's your week that's my
weakness apparently there's a rap it
could have been girls I think there are
a couple other ones gotcha
crab people made sense to me okay so
this is funny oh yeah wrong button so I
have firecrackers that's the only key
[Music]
my bad on the twitch naming I thought I
picked the fractured foot we good now
this is pretty funny
alright ooh captain diabetes so this
this is a little spoiler but again this
is early on if you're watching don't
worry but this is it's minor okay cool
so this is at night if you're I remember
when I first had this happen to me I was
like oh yeah I can go talk to Randy so
let's see if he's here so he was the one
that was keying his own car
[Music]
[Music]
so yeah you want to get also you want to
surround enemies a lot of times because
yeah you get that combo by pushing or
knock back into another teammate hey
Matthew Hall we're not too far in we did
some early stuff earlier in the stream
now we're kind of like one for one to
two hours in or something
I think from what I saw on your TV has a
lot of life dude
[Music]
movie slow
[Music]
so like this is early on and even this
was kind of slow combat yeah like check
on oh [ __ ] no oh it's on master my see
this is a save where I had I had it like
tried out mastermind for a while and do
this and see how quickly they help much
quicker and that was the hardest
difficulty yeah and again as mentioned
earlier the race slider thing about
difficulty doesn't do anything such a
joke and if from your experience
mastermind just makes things longer
right yeah
but like I think it becomes more more
pressing like I know this is very slow
comma because it's only two characters
or three four counting the enemies so
it's not as interesting it's it's kind
of not what it's not what the game can
really get to like when there's a full
team of like four before or like just
four people on your team because you'll
have different types of bosses some of
them will be like will kind of break the
rules of turn-based where it's like a
timer or if you don't act quick enough
they're gonna advance so there's like
one where you're like you're being
pushed along kind of like um oh I can do
this I'll do it with with diabetes
because it's kind of fun but one soul
will probably part like another 30 40
minutes
yeah Moses a is
regarding Oh like remember Mario's with
Mario rabbits there isn't just like kill
all the enemies there's like different
objectives yeah
ones like get through the level or some
get through as fast you can or else
you'll be crushed by something so I'll
show you the diabetes super
[Music]
so I like the Gavin to the crew that a
sink how was it yeah look what you
he just says myself
I agree Jacob that [ __ ] joke never gets
old off with this he's kind of tricky
after this I could show my save it's
like a little past halfway it's fine
maybe that's something we could do in
the very last it happens after this I
can show just like more of the combat
with like a full team and other
characters I don't think it's that
spoiler
do you run out of firecrackers or now
now all this is is infinite you can use
firecrackers to light candles
sometimes yeah there's a fart one then
you get more later on baby eat
underscore beans this game gets released
tonight by 9 p.m. Pacific 12 a.m. and
Rob kinda answered this others a yahoo
says there's a little bit of a slow burn
in terms of the beginning of this
compared to stick of truth I think but
it kind of gets it gets there yeah like
[Music]
so obviously the blue here this is like
main main questline more or less I would
get through that I would keep playing
that until it might get you and guy you
need to have more of a might level you
might need to do a couple of these side
missions to get along but like you know
like most games the main quest will
grant you all the abilities so like
another thing was like there are again
things in the environment that you need
to have a certain power for in order to
like get through like a chest so I was
doing a lot of the exploring pretty
heavy on and ran across so many of these
like gated like chests and areas I was
like well I might as well come back
later on I post it like retracing my
steps time and time and edge stronger or
farther because a lot of a lot of them
are like 2 hours up to like you know in
my play like 5 hours 10 hours so it's
like it's kind of needless to like
explore the whole town wrap the back
[Music]
Oh
only it was so simple captured diabetes
[Music]
yeah yeah peppermint hippo
it's like Spearmint Rhino peppermint
hippo there's one we've already seen
this before but there's a lot of nudity
in it I think I'm gonna change the save
you don't need to do anything all right
I'm gonna try to track it with the
picture-in-picture just block everything
out with it us but you know I can turn
up the game a little bit louder come you
know Vaughn a Crone just told me if you
can't hear us because of it so we want
to go you did the burrito Whisperer so
unfortunately I was like I don't so this
is where I am where I am now this is
life and this is where we are now we are
now we could do some more sites
questions or two where I am
I mean you choose we got we got about 25
minutes okay there do this so we can at
least like the show more of the combat
because I think that's kind of something
that spontaneous bootay has an instant
kill ass damn my app you can change the
combat challenge in the combat a second
we need that thanks for the hot tip I
hope I'm not at the strip club okay
camera no I mean I we're not in case
just in case no okay now you're good
all right switching back we good so what
am I at now oh yeah I'm at like 270
might little damn what's max we don't
even know I got a new slot here so yeah
and you're just kind of always tossing
in these artifacts craft what like 11
hours into the game yeah okay I did a
lot with the sides and there's another
one once we hit we're hero rank 8 right
and then the this is something you
unlock eventually which is this is where
like you know as your artifacts do
different things to your stats like your
brains or or you know attack or health
you can kind of come back to this one
and like even it out
mmm to kind of cater back to like maybe
like you prefer you know more brains
gotcha
then health if you find the game you
know the gingers it's too difficult like
I have this one on or my health is a
little low because I've been doing okay
like you know I'm my main super here in
the bottom left is like a healing power
to like all my core class this time more
or less this is my role yeah so I have
the ANA mental elemental power that I'm
not gonna do the boss battle in the
strip club unfortunately it would
probably be risky business the bet the
swearing's already pretty bad but yeah I
think a little nudity would probably get
us in some troubles so we're gonna skip
that side quests here's the yeah we
project you're below Rick you know I'm
below but you know what on the way I'll
do oh wait the cop station maybe that's
what it is looks like it
oh good good yeah it just seems long
risky as fast as my reflexes are I don't
think I could block everything out so I
just have to you know oh no you can't
you won't be they would be wiser than
one oh yeah not curious about the
streamers have like done it because it's
part of the story mission so it's like
yeah it is in trouble for that I would
assume it's breaking Terms of Service
but hmm
also in the game we're not gonna take
that risk though no sorry kid politics
oh wait what do you mean last time he's
telling me where to go so okay I go to
the mayor's house let's go into the
street and I'll show you a fight stick
well let's go to the strip club
absolutely not with black rectangles
yeah I would need a couple black
rectangles probably
I could ask but it's gonna be by the
time again the answer if I wouldn't be
in time so we're just gonna Skip's oh
okay so this is something I can do how
do you have little mini parts good
question no it's it's an ability
oh it's both sorry I'm like I can like
rewind objects and time there's that
thing that shares of shiny in the car
yeah
I gotta get it down so let's keep going
Hey look we're back hope you just left
oh no cheerleaders actually do this real
quick so I can change later
oh you're gonna so if I punch your first
than I get the upper hand doing things
raising girls let's change from this
team up oh look you got a call girl yeah
she's great
just Wendy so we haven't seen Carmen
from the kick in and let's pick Fast
Pass Fast Pass yeah give us a Fast Pass
okay yeah right no fast should be good I
don't I guess I'm the healer for the
most part so that's a havoc dog saying
I'm pretty sure you don't get in trouble
as long as they aren't too realistic
nude images
oh man they're vomiting fired on before
this is a cool move I have so the
elemental one like that that cypher neck
one I can put her against her own team
sick turn them against each other yeah I
think it doesn't happen all the time
though now she'll now attack the other
raisins so saying to do the Craig Craig
mission I mean I don't I don't have that
save
we don't worry we got him oh man he's
invisible so Carmen also does kind of
like a bleed move I think they were
doing this earlier go get him call girl
Oh a selfie stick yeah she got a selfie
stick yeah she does huh that's a good
one team Wyatt is equals nobody so now
she was gonna charm me and put me
against my team I would lose the ability
so I'm the rewind time I got one of
these every like three or four turns
yeah strategy strategy right hot strats
it's morning you could take tune
[Music]
that's awesome Danny hits hard yeah dude
Jimmy ain't messing around
I like Jimmy 153 that's why I can swap
an enemy when I bring like you know I
got like a stronger enemy instead of
like we're all my team do you want to
see we're definitely not taking the risk
so there is no questioning that for sure
[Music]
ultimate ultimate his ultimate isn't
that cool
I know I want you know you are see you
want to see you all right fair enough
Jimmy's will do Jimmy's oh yeah carbons
is pretty funny because the ultimate is
a fight base right it's not like you
would have it next time right okay so
only one I can only do it I can show why
Jimmy
it's around the world yeah that's what
the flash with you
nice job new kid keep it up that's right
you got flash past so that's a challenge
I'm kind of working towards so let's
look again see what else I can do this
is main story obviously
oh that's Mitch Conner I think we'll be
okay if we go to Coons lair these are
all kind of like just like you know kind
of boring collectibles [ __ ] like I
wouldn't want to do that okay like I
said you do you maybe we can do that
actually let's try this one
yes it's all good goob I mean at this
point we're almost wrapping up the
stream so I'm not even gonna we're not
gonna head into that at all head into
law because he was confirming or denying
if you could actually do a strip club
oh yeah I guess have you said it too
mature on like twitches stuff father
you've seen it before I think also we
have gameplay of it yeah we're from e3
right yeah we do we can stop in tweeks
coffee I love that tweaks dad I'd hit it
looks pretty fast though yeah
surprisingly yeah sometimes I think for
the most part it's it's been pretty
smooth
definitely I've heard of some issues of
life saves today have you seen our
seasonal menu it's like putting on your
favorite flannel shirt so yeah but like
40 years you're buying a lot
french-press sports bottles is like
revived or like remove statuses and then
artifacts so like this is pretty good
Dan that was 40 bucks man that's fine I
haven't sold a lot of like my older ones
that so just go to here this is kind of
a lot of what you're doing get that
might up yeah geez okay that wasn't even
the one you bought I know I don't know
where I got that oh I have an idea where
actually that's to keep going
BAM it's almost like a joke to me
how quit a 90 something oh did I and
then what's being used is anyone okay
it's kind of like a joke in its own
right how quickly you go from like 200
to like just 300 as you saw right there
like it's funny yeah all right let's
look in the back here I want to see if
there's guy let me know know tweekaz
back here earlier let's see what
dang little psyops costume dare you
bring order to chaos hero chaos is like
eighth graders will be like if you walk
away they'll be like yeah keep walking
[ __ ] it's typical 8th grade yeah if you
guys are just tuning in we were playing
South Park the fractured but whole this
is a little bit of a later game let's
save we're not gonna show too much as
the story but we're just showing off
some of the so we're gonna have to see
if he's bum bum fights
alright let's change up Jimmy
Apache master so difficulty mastermind
is the hardest one you can pick you can
change that anytime it kind of just
looked like it takes longer but you guys
can try that out and in terms of like
the race and slider and difficulty
there's nothing that's just a joke so I
can't use Stan unfortunately he's locked
is it because you're using someone else
no I think there's something in a story
where he's doing something else
is there anyone we haven't seen yet not
really and we've seen everyone now that
you have so far yeah I'm sure there's
more boys have so many unlockables like
four more Yeah right
all right let's go with this again then
all right let's do it
take this bums what's up cute animal
squad oh there's four of them now we
have a wife-beater guy come from
deceiving these bums they just
multiplied Danny's got a lot of health
yeah so let's have that guy maybe he's
the big the head as a hobo see if this
guy
[Music]
spare change
Oh what happened to him
get him Jimmy so I can swap the players
of my
possibly sheets he said like what about
the sixth grader fight in the beginning
thought that I had to do something to do
with difficulty yeah there was one fight
where they were yeah like there as a
tutorial but it's like hey this is the
difficulty what do you think that you
want to change it so I did I was like no
I'll try mastermind and then I like got
through it okay and then haven't didn't
change it for a while but now I'm
playing on okay I believe it or this
Mike's a blocking it yeah this guy's so
Boston roads just need to stand here
you [ __ ] with the [ __ ] you answered to
it friend rag guys binging you is on my
system do this
packmaster saying I just asked because
stacking status effects on the last game
pretty much appropriate I hope this one
is a bit harder has it been that
difficulty difficult for you though
since you're now it has we been at least
two thirds of the way plus in uh only
once or twice I like was careless and
lost a fight but for the most part it's
been easy but again like that's kind of
how I'm playing this as I want to not
have difficult combat like I just want
to get to the meet you know that's Joe's
yeah you know so just tell me when it
comes down to it and that's what I love
about it more so than like you know
great game mechanics which do you know
it's not to say that this is not fun
it's fun but it's not what I'm when
you're here for all the fun South Park
please
yeah four dollars beer and crack or he
needs money for he's honest
Asian elephant teen once in a hot combat
system is prepared to the first one I'd
say more so now it's like centered on
team structure and like layouts it later
on like if you again if you were to
crank up the difficulty even more like
you're more reliant on like pay
attention to your team layout like all
right I want to make sure like I have
like a good healer like I'll and I don't
think the first game had much of that it
was just more turn base like I want to
say QTE detects a turn
it's a good one I want to show Eric
Cartman's all right oh no oh wow that's
new
catfight grossed out
damaged and confusing what's up in our
9r head this is not multiplayer and
singleplayer
yep you're bleeding and Bob alright I'm
just gonna pass all right show me that
hot Cartman all slow there okay here we
go
this one's pretty fun oh just gonna
knock them out for sure
[Music]
that was at 12 health though but it was
bleeding it's like because everyone he's
getting interview for what the hell that
was good
Oh everyone lives yeah that's kind of a
game inside the Actor's Studio go okay
meet her in the bathroom
dang in the bathroom huh
[Music]
oh right because I picked you pick your
gender
I think it's wrong they make cisgendered
people share a bathroom it must be so
hard for you anyway I've got a problem
new kid I'm like you an outsider I've
been watching as adults in our town act
stranger and stranger but nobody will
listen to me
I started cross-referencing everyone's
instagrams to see what kind of
connection I could find and that's when
it happened somebody cancelled my
cellular data plan my phone is dead
whoever did this has to pay I'm going to
the mobile company to find out what
happened I can't go alone oh sure I'm
asking for your help new kid I think
you're the only one who understands yeah
a new kid do you think we have enough
time to help her do that well we'll see
if there's a story either joke but if
there's if it's another fight we'll just
cut it before okay we have what like six
minutes I mean we couldn't go a little
longer sure it isn't ready it's not like
so let's just finish request assuming
it's not super long okay let's just do
it
they want me mobile so that's
so yeah if you guys have any last-minute
questions I why not we are on one more
we're gonna do one more story beat here
or enough story beat sorry side mission
here and I'll show this so this is where
like you know like the last game you had
like different fart moves right that you
unlocks this one has the same and I'll
show you one of them I don't know why I
wasn't working
oh I have to be up there so I have to be
up there in order to get to this other
roof so I have to get I need your help
dang look at parkour parkour parkour
sorry parkour this is where you're
getting look at that fits and stuff so
then I think I had yeah
Otis here okay
or fork or nailed it nailed it
alright ok nothing for that one
what was it I missed it yeah it's just
like a mystery alright so let's just say
that your your butt and your farts are
always in relation to like other kids
superheroes you're helping them out with
your farts so another question coming
through the map looks pretty much the
same as the first one from knee to knee
into the stream are there new areas I'd
say so I forget what season I want to
say this is like this takes place like
the end of season 20 which was last year
so obviously the new stuff season 21 has
been up and running since I left over
but I feel like that's where the status
of the town is left off so like there's
like so Hopa whatever that whole area is
like under ruins to the left another
bottom right and then like the South
Park malls destroyed for sure something
happened in this last season had that
caused a let's do it
Oh your weakness the people who worked
here last week I knew it the phone
company's been taken over by crap people
so for those of you just tuning in one
of the first things you do in the game
is you pick your kryptonite maybe fourth
graders or girls and I picked crab
people so here comes the weakness
I'm charming him so easily L clearly
that guy will fight his other one as a
teammate
[Music]
super effective
ooh ooh down that crab defeat this king
crab
Oh what customers do yeah yeah oh I got
a call that King that's this one kill
him he probably keeps telling ya he know
he will for sure
that's like that can definitely happen
us
[Music]
crabs okay I didn't hurt that bad so
this is something I I can you should
have saved that for when he's about to
heal someone are you froze time yeah but
I've never really figured this one out
because I can't seem to like hit him oh
okay oh you could it didn't work I
cooked on more I had that I just got
that power okay that makes more sense
now oh yeah good stuff just need one
more phone destroyer oh yeah king crab
yeah suck at crab people who what's that
subdermal me so I think she's officially
what a character I can use I think
nobody I know but like I got that
mutation too so that that's where you're
balancing out right right
so that makes sense I'm getting those
DNA abilities after each boss smelled
like crab and kissed like people how can
we repay you just get my phone all right
yes yes of course call girl thanks for
saving the mobile store once again
thanks new kid but I have a feeling this
isn't over
if you snow crab call me pollute their
bodies
yeah I get that king crabs boot with
those crab people gone I finally have a
shot at employee of the month now the
one of the grabs I have is that do these
selfies but they're always the same face
so I can like change the smile of you
but not them yeah they always have the
exact same expression face
it's that triangle smile head tilt but
much more that was a kind of just a
quick look all around beginning kind of
early hour and then a little bit later
of a South Park the fractured but whole
the review is up
Miguel concepcion on the video review is
also up we give it an 8 which is great
so if you're curious check that out
tonight I'm assuming 9 p.m. Pacific ish
which is 12 a.m. Eastern
but thanks Rob yeah thanks Eric I don't
thoughts about the game final thoughts
are if you will not final but I guess
you have yeah probably my own
impressions are like I'm a huge South
Park fan I really am so I would say if
if you're in South America you should
definitely get this it's worthwhile just
say that like keep playing the main
quest lines if you want more of like
what you came for like myself which is
you know just the South Park Trey Parker
and Matt Stone making jokes yeah I would
say go for it like I love the last game
I'm getting up about the same experience
so it's good stuff awesome
yeah so as always we're always live
always live every day at 11:00 Monday to
Friday tomorrow's Tuesday
I'm guessing it's probably gonna be a
destiny weekly update kind of stream
thing but if something else comes up
it'll probably that but yeah Wednesday
is a lobby 11 a.m. and so forth and so
on
so until we guys until we see you guys
next time think that's all for tuning in
if you haven't hit the like follow or
subscribe button you guys should do that
but until next time see y'all later
thanks Rob
[Music]